hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in a short but
influential essay what is art and
institutional analysis George Dickey
will set out a mini history of attempt
to define art and then denials of that
and then yet a further attempt which is
his own proposal of the institutional
theory of art that depends on the art
world and he begins by framing this in
terms of three phases and if we're
thinking about the history of creation
of art and talking about art and
philosophical reflection on art the
first phase occupies most of human
history the second phase would be a
relatively short time largely within the
20th century and then the third and
final phase in this this analysis or
this this schema would be the current
time whether we call it an institutional
theory of art or not it would be the
time of Dickies theory which does
provide some sort of definition of art
but a different sort than the earlier
definitions so he calls this phase 1
phase 2 and phase 3 phase 1 he talks
about as the traditional attempts to
define art from the imitation theory on
so he mentions two main theories of art
that is theories of what constitutes the
work of art as opposed to everything
else or what defines the work of art one
of these is the imitation theory and we
can call it representation theory we can
call it mimetic theory these are all
more or less the same and it gets its
real start within the West at least with
Plato saying that artwork is is merely
there's a value judgment there imitation
of realities ways of depicting things
and this would go even for creatures
that that never really existed like
centaurs as far as we know you take you
know in the imagination the torso of a
human being
torso and head and arms and you plop it
onto the body of a horse - the head of
the horse and boom you got a centaur now
you can draw it or paint it or sculpt it
or discuss it in literature or depict it
in some other ways and as deke points
out you know there have always been some
problems with this theory when we're
thinking about art
okay so theater would be representation
of human actions on the stage like
Aristotle said also representation of
their thoughts and words and spectacle
but what about music does music
represent it's always been kind of
difficult to say precisely what music is
supposed to be doing given this
imitation theory I mean we could say
well you know people are imitating
birdcalls or something like that but
that doesn't help that much and it's
also difficult when we're thinking about
poetry and language and those sorts of
things so there are some problems with
the imitative
theory of art and he goes on and he says
there's another possibility as well the
theory of art as expression of emotion
and he says this has focused on a
different property of the works of art
the relation of a work to its creator
and so we say things like well you know
artistic works are things in which we
express our thoughts or we express our
emotions or we express our experiences
we express something and you know you
could think of Leo Tolstoy you know art
is supposed to produce communion through
sharing of emotions as a prime example
of this but there's many other sub fear
E's that that also viewed art and
artistic activities and products as
essentially engaging in expression and
these two kind of battled for quite a
while and both of them were ultimately
shown to be inadequate as theories of
art so he says the expression theory is
also proved inadequate no other
subsequent definition has been
satisfactory although not as fully
satisfying as definitions however
the imitation and expression theories do
provide a clue so they weren't a
complete loss both singled-out
relational properties of art as
essential and he thinks you know that
there was some advance in doing so so
the process of trying to say what is art
what constitutes art what is essential
to art even if it failed it turned out
to be quite useful then we move into
phase 2 what happens in phase 2 well in
the 20th century a lot of theorists
start despairing of the idea that we'll
ever really be able to define
art in terms of necessary and sufficient
conditions in terms of a traditional
definition where you know the word for
definition Horus and Greek actually
means boundary so think of a circle in
which you've got everything that's that
thing inside everything that's not that
thing outside we want everything that's
art inside and we don't want anything
that's not art inside that circle we
want all that out of the circle
what is the border what allows us to
define this some people said well we're
never going to arrive in anything it's
it's not simply you know imitation or
expression or any essential thing that
we could point our finger to and say aha
this is what all art has in common all
works of art share in this essence and
there were a lot of ways of doing this
there is you know use of Vidkun Stinney
in ideas you know the notion that Vidkun
Stein had that what what actually is a
game we can't quite say what a game is
with any sort of definition because any
any way that we try to define it any
characteristic that we pick out there's
always something that seems to be an
exception and yet is a game our game is
supposed to be fun what about games that
are deadly serious are games involving
winning and losing what about throwing a
ball against the wall you know and we
can go on and on you may have read
vacant science philosophical
investigations in which he formulates
this which had an incredible effect on
the art world and there were other
people who are raising similar arguments
he brings up Morris vices article the
role of theory in aesthetics and two
arguments that he's providing a
generalization argument a classification
argument and he examines and discards
them there that's not really quite so
important as far as the development goes
but a point that Maurice mandelbaum as
he says raised about victim Stein's
famous contention that game cannot be
defined and vices theory about art is
juror
main here he says that the challenge to
both is based on the charge that they've
been concerned only with what mandelbaum
calls exhibited characteristics
exhibited characteristics would be
things like is an imitation of something
real or the product of a composition of
imitation of something real or is an
expression of emotion thoughts desires
whatever it is that we're going to say
in an expressive theory those would be
exhibited characteristics Dickie goes on
and says that mandelbaum is right in
talking about non exhibited relational
aspects of game and art so what do we
what are we talking about there he says
my exhibited characteristics mandelbaum
means easily perceived properties like a
ball being used in a certain kind of
game or a painting having a triangular
composition or the plot of a tragedy
contains a reversal of fortune
what would a non exhibited
characteristic be it would be something
much more complex much more relational
based in something else and actually
Vidkun stein is providing some sort of
clues here with his notion of language
game but also a form of life that's
irreducible to a set of rules so phase
two does serve some sort of purpose in
that it helps to show the problems the
failings of the previous theories of art
that people were relying on now notice
that Dicky is not saying oh well bad
theory we get rid of it entirely we
reject it it's thrown away it's canceled
to use today's parlance no instead we
need something that can incorporate
what's right in those but also get
beyond what was wrong so this is where
he proposes an institutional theory of
art and this is going to focus
non exhibited relational aspects uses a
couple different words here aspects
features or characteristics of works of
art and here is where he brings in
something that he doesn't originate
himself but takes from arthur danto the
notion of the art world the art world as
he says is an entire broad social
institution in which works of art have
their place and he notes that there are
systems within the art world so drama is
or theatre is a system painting is a
system sculpture is a system literature
can be understood as a system and he
says that each of the systems has had
its own origins and historical
development you can't reduce it down to
an essence you have to look at these
things historically and you might even
say sociologically although he doesn't
use that word in this this discussion
now he tells us that one central feature
all the systems have in common is that
each is a framework for the presenting
of particular works of art and it
provides us with a way of saying this is
art this is not art at least in what
he's going to call a classifications but
also in the evaluative sense in in which
we say this is a good work of art or
this is really a work of art right with
sort of emphasis in the voice so this
third way of looking at things allows us
to get beyond these these earlier
theories get beyond the rejection of
them and provide something like
necessary and sufficient conditions and
he will do so in in you know defining a
work of art as a artifact a set of the
aspects of which has had conferred upon
it the status of candidate for
appreciation by some person or persons
acting on behalf of a certain social in
tution ie the art world and he points
out that there's several features to
this which we'll look at elsewhere these
are acting on behalf of an institution
conferring status being a candidate and
appreciation along with this also goes
artifact Xu ality there has to be some
sort of doing something some
transforming something in the process
I'm producing a product and Diggy thinks
that this theory and definition of art
can explain to us what art really is and
how we can make sense of it he does say
that a little bit later some may have
the uncomfortable feeling that his
definition is viciously circular and he
says that it is circular but not
viciously so it's it's providing us a
genuine understanding of what's going on
when we say that something is art when
we sell something is art when we
classify it as art when we produce it
and when we hang it so towards the end
of his essay he then says once the
institutional nature of art is noted the
roles that such theory of art is the
imitation and expression theories played
in thinking about art can be seen in an
interesting perspective for example as
long as all art was thought to be
imitative imitation was thought to be a
universal property of art but then we
realize no no there's more to art than
merely imitation so long as we turned
our attention to expressivity that was
taken to be the essence of art this what
we earlier calling exhibited qualities
or properties and so he says the role
played by the expression theory was
different from that of the imitation
theory it was seen as a replacement and
served as its correction developments
and art had shown that the imitation
theory was incorrect it was quite
natural to
look for a substitute that focused on
another exhibited property of art in
this case its expressive qualities
interpreting them as expressions of the
artists and then he says you know we had
to go through this period of doubting
whether we could come up with a
definition and now we have a
satisfactory definition by reference to
the art world the institutional theory
of art that allows us now to understand
what the essence of art is which turns
out to be a complex relation to the art
world
you